go back please all right um you want to
be able to see so I wouldn't be so far
okay so the um in this in this one like
I said we're going to go over your
individual common mistakes uh because
they're common they're going to be
common to everyone okay
um this one uh I'm going to let you guys
bring up your mistakes uh or I'll
observe them and will address them you
can
relax and uh this one was Leah's and
she's not here so I have to introduce it
and if I leave anything out lace you
just because you were there when she
talked about it okay uh she said kind of
innocently I can on certain ukas I can
feel the resistance and then on other
ukas I can feel them relaxing it seems
like a very innocent statement and you
go that's true okay and I think I think
we have as we demonstrated uh with v the
resistance is coming from what and you
can answer cuz you already have it right
now what is the resistance coming from
fear fear of what fear of the pain fear
of the pain do you see that okay uh and
then though how how do I feel it was the
question like how do you know they're
tents and I said use the yinong equation
right right so you could see here
I'm resisting his resistance that's how
I would be able to subjectively sense
that he's resisting because T up and uh
lay it there tens I don't feel his
resistance but for him pushing down on
my leg so I move away I don't feel his
resistance okay so my sensation of his
resistance is only possible by my
resistance to his resistance do you get
that okay and if you don't buy that then
you should stop your iido training
because that's yinyang Theory okay and
that is also our path to Salvation
meaning I'm in control of my suffering
do you see because it's what I bring to
the equation that makes up the suffering
okay so therefore if I don't bring the
missing element to the equation I do not
not suffer I do not cause suffering okay
all right
so where did I do I feel his resistance
I feel it here at his wrist got it well
that's why you don't do it you're not
doing it by trying to turn his wrist
around okay uh remember on you rain when
I if you try to turn my wrist around his
resistance is too strong for me I can't
do it I could not do it on you maybe
someone much much bigger than me can go
ahead and overpower that resistance do
you see that
but that is not the art okay so what
we're going to do is actually not deal
with his wrist at all we're going to
deal with this part over
here this part the lock or the hold is
in this part okay not not over here
trying to do this
okay and we'll get there eventually but
what I'm going to do is put this
part where it fits in my body
here do you see that okay and then uh
what I'm going to loosen up a little cuz
he's getting tighter okay uh so this
angle is not good for this is me
loosening it up for him but what I want
you to see is that I'm going to come
back in there's a place where it fits
you see and I don't actually have to
hold it you know this from other
techniques you have so I'm going to do
Niko It Go that thumb that thumb goes
right in that clavicle right underneath
that clavicle you see some of you are
like here and then why does his hand
keep slipping
down you see
it's not seated in what what Parker Mr
Parker would called A fitting fitting
strip so when it when it's fit you you
don't need the all the grips you don't
need all the grips to hold it do you
see you're using your body to help you
out so first thing is for Leah get off
of this stop making a big deal out of
this thing
okay come over here
where it fits where you don't need
anything and now as you've done that
you've given yourself a larger Force
engine than this here because here I'm
using my
body you see my whole body can go in you
well good
up okay and so he's pushing I'm not
trying to go with this small engine I
have my whole body you see that you so
you bring it to a larger Force engine
right at the same
time that you're going around where his
actual he wants this down and off do you
see he he wants it down off he puts it
back on the mat so he can get back up
you get it so you go you you can do
whatever you want buddy with that part
okay and you're over here like this okay
so I'm here like this let's demonstrate
that it's in place without any grips and
I have a very slippery shirt right now
if you pay attention and so does he but
still anatomically it'll lock in place
and we'll just go to here to here okay
let's try that part and you'll see I
don't need to contend with that wrist at
all okay
go already slight deviation okay already
slight deviation and there the more you
deviate from the form it takes away from
your mechanical Advantage okay so for
example this is a huge deviation from
the form uh where this elbow is on the
back side of my uh Center Line okay but
when you put it on the center line and
but you're like I just I'm I'm over a
little do you see I'm I'm P zbow past my
Center Line just a little I did it
Sensei but on our slippery shirts here
that thing's going to come out you see
and but more partic more more
particularly is uh uh he has this right
angle to his elbow and you want this
angle to be ever so slightly ahead you
get it so you can you mark the knee yeah
Sensei said that knee goes there and
it's supposed to be on the other side of
my center line but there it wouldn't
stay so I'm going to move it ahead you
see it's ever so slightly ahead you guys
see that and then now it's in place so
there's where you are
he and here's where I am
okay you do you see that okay so let us
look so here he's he's uh got all the
mechanical advantage on me and I cannot
get this technique to go okay I couldn't
do it on rain either all right here when
we're here you all right okay so when
I'm here he's very so straight up and
down he's very close to it so and uh go
ahead don't let me do it and he can
eventually straighten his arm and now
I'm back in the worst so you see but
when you put his arm at
this let me get a more uh
Flex so when you take take
away take when you take away that angle
and make his arm go diagonally here do
you see it can you see it yes s okay
then so feel your strength capacity here
yeah and then you make this go
diagonally there's he he loses the the
strength and in fact his
resistance now pushes into mine and the
yin yangong equation works against him
you see so he pushes and it he's putting
the lock on himself now do you guys see
that so you don't you you will have
those super flexible ukes you might have
to go here but you just can't be here
the elbow has to give some sort of
forward diagonal to it okay all right
let's add that
to uh you're going to switch rolls first
stand up by each
other okay so we can see this okay all
right
um there's two things you're trying to
do when you're meeting Force equations
one we discussed in the first uh demo is
you're trying to use larger Force
engines but two in the second demo which
we're going to emphasize here is I'm
trying to take away their larger Force
engines okay and of the two the second
one is the most important one okay so
you're going to go
down good and you want to make you want
to P don't do the technique in your mind
you're going to make sure that you have
a forward can to his elbow so you don't
have enough yet do you understand there
you go okay all right and secure your
grip on the Trap and the lat all right
Chris uh you're going to uh resist her
technique go Chris go okay you got
really come nope go back in all right go
go Chris your hardest your hardest your
hardest your
hardest good okay so you see what
happened is she took away his larger
Force engines by getting that forward
can and your size how much you weigh 128
128 and Chris 200 200 lb okay so sh sh
can keep that guy's uh 200 lb man's arm
in that hold if done this way okay all
right let's go okay so just to why I
have you guys in in without your geese
so that you could see more uh where
things go okay um
the taller UK is going to have a arm
that's going to lend itself more to
positioning the elbow as we just said
than the shorter UK so often times
because of our fear pride in
ignorance we believe the technique's
going to fail more from the bigger guy
or in the face of the bigger guy and
uh when instead often it's the smaller
UK who may not overpower
me but I'm not supposed to overpower
that UK do you see so that's an
irrelevant
May uh but they may provide additional
difficulties to gaining the mechanics
that we're trying to use okay why
because they uh uh elbow is can't get
where it needs to be do you see that
okay uh so there's there's very little
that I can do I can kind of get it do
you see what I did how I'm doing this so
you you're going to you're going to get
it okay but you can see if I'm not
paying attention and you're like I just
come here like this the elbow is at my
pelvis line and you're
like do you understand so you have to
with within the form are you all right
we'll switch
sides uh
within the form you want to try to find
the form again and is that already
hurting no I'm good all right
um there's several ways to seek a
lowering of your torso the easiest way
is to free your mind from the shoulder
pinch do you see because that makes me
that basically that's as high as I could
be in Kiza is the closer my knees are
together the higher my head comes off
the mat okay just like the tallest I am
is when my feet are together this is
going to make me shorter okay well same
thing
here as I said in the first video why
you should Free Yourself of the shoulder
pinch is because uh martially it doesn't
do anything for me so uh I can't pinch
her
shoulder and she can still do the roll
do you know how to do it nope wrong
shoulder yes there you go you see there
no amount of pinch is going to stop that
from happening okay so you only need
this
component to get and keep her in place
you see between this hold this hold and
that hold boom I have it okay this is
not relevant to it so you can open your
knee and now my Center
got lower do you see and I'm in place
the other thing you can do because this
knee is not relevant is move up the
circle you see how I did that and
that'll lower my Center even more as I
bring a rotation into this state so I do
the same lock here still have her
forward C
okay um so we'll have Sean come
out that push there that you feel on
your chest yes that means stay there
please okay so he's taller and you can
see this the elbow is not over here so
you need
this and now you have to figure it
out without taking
that
okay
okay so what he wants to do with his
hands is gain more control for the
position of the elbow do you see that
and now you understand what your arms
are actually
doing
he they are keeping that elbow where it
needs to be do you got it okay keep this
there and you get that forward C you
look like there you go there you go nice
and
tight
okay and now she you'll do the
pit pushing this elbow forward this
elbow goes this way this this elbow I'm
going to hold you keep your grip this
elbow goes this way
he there you go okay so I'll go
in and if you pay
attention that camp yeah you were
forward of it but she has all
this you see so when you take her into
this technique at the end of katama you
take her to this point she should not
land here she should not land here she
should land over here do you
see do you understand okay um so just to
make that point it was made in the first
video this is the ending of
katame and they should be brought to
this ending with the pin already in
place we should not bring them to this
ending and now
do a pin okay and even if I landed here
this is not her hold do you get it so we
should not see all this mve movement in
our technique okay she she should land
here she should land there you see and
then you're doing the technique so that
was me applying the pin at that point
and to you it's
imperceptible that uh I moved at all but
she she feels it obviously and what is
she feeling then if it's not me
traversing the map she's feeling the
internal
pressurization and the uh C dropping do
you see just like on your compound lifts
that you're doing that's what she's
feeling okay and it starts to just
tighten everything
okay all right so let's work with
different size UK and some will be
taller some will be shorter it doesn't
really matter some will be stronger it
doesn't really matter okay let's
go a long time you see did you see
yes okay uh let's do the other other
side you were doing before
okay so you got everything in place go
ahead like we got there okay now
sometimes it's confusing on the what
angle to take okay and the Ang the
angle becomes confusing because your
fear starts to set in so you're looking
for ways of overpowering her you don't
realize it but you are so you will feel
what whatever resistance is in the
natural uh flexibility or lack thereof
and then you want to push it and so
you're going to take the wrong angle or
you're
like f her I'm going to crush her you
see and then you try to crush her and
you're pressing down now and what
happens is that you don't you wasted
this is all useless because you're
taking the elbow to the wrong angle okay
so if we look at your Technique it's
it's not diagonally forward enough so
let me have you first correct
that and she has it on her thigh do you
see when it so leave leave leave it
there it's on your thigh and it's
supposed to be here okay but and so this
is a deviation so now my work output
starts to go down and her work output
starts to reach greater potential so
your Force engine gets smaller
her Force engine gets stronger okay all
right so let's see what we're doing now
with the
path okay so if you pay attention this
you keep doing what you're doing this
elbow's going this way it's going this
way as she's doing it further into your
leg that means it's not going anywhere
cuz your leg is stopping it okay so try
a different angle you don't have to
reset every go ahead okay I don't want
you to think I'm cheating you okay you
go ahead and she's starting to go around
the elbow now she changed it when my
hand came over to correct her she's I
must be doing something wrong okay but
go ahead and make that mistake again
she's going around the top of the elbow
do you see the hand is getting closer to
the back okay so let me
in okay so you see all that slack all
that slack has to be taken out to there
okay and then this elbow goes this way
this way you see so there here's my
slack is gone you went this
way then the other time you're going
over the top of it okay so slack on and
then this elbow goes this way so
demonstrate
it the two things okay so I get it all
in
place well there's where the slack is
gone so that's where I would have ended
up in the technique
then you're starting to go this way but
my leg's in the way so you feel the
resistance which is actually your
resistance cuz your leg is in the way
and you start doing
this or you go D she's not doing it so
you start this and you watch your elbow
it's not
moving you see that so you're going to
take this elbow and you're going to move
it this way boom like that boom
that way with my body okay now if I
turn what happens to this side of the
cylinder that is by torso it's going
backwards you see so you turn and you're
taking you're actually taking it off so
you don't turn this thing everything
goes whole this way just like if you
move out of the way please uh go to go
this way and I'm walking this
way okay all right let's try uh same
side
please all right so this is another
common mistake uh you already received
the correction but go ahead and make the
mistake again he's going to go over the
top of the elbow do you see he's going
over the top and now what he's doing is
he's he's uh uh allowing for the slack
that is still in the ball and socket
joint to be utilized by her so uh you're
going to do it again he's going to go up
you're going to go up you see and what
happens is uh he's starting to turn her
and because the shoulder is itself not
being pinned down which is should be
pinned down uh as you're doing the
technique so wait stand by we just want
to see it from this angle and you're
going to go up over and it starts to
turn her do you see that ever so
slightly okay uh so let me in there
Chris so again I'm here and you see
there's space there you see that okay so
I don't want that space there you see
how I did that okay and then when you
start to go up I'm bringing that space
back into there okay you see that so
instead it should go
down you see that because remember it's
a k ho I'm not trying to I don't I
wouldn't say this is hurting him at all
so uh I don't want to say I'm not trying
to out March on him cuz it's really
you're opening up the hold but as the
cke you hold
everything
drops okay got it okay so don't pick
them up again in your in
your anxiousness to do something to them
okay all right let's go